Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
spider-man 3 Daredevil video comicbook.com is
reporting that charlie cox just finished filming
his scenes on the set of the spider-man 3 movie
within days of kevin feige doing a huge round
of interviews about bringing back the marvel
netflix characters in the mcu so we'll break it
all down but if you're a big supporter of the save
daredevil campaign it sounds like that totally
worked because it now sounds like daredevil has
been saved and will show up in new mcu projects
and disney plus series if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's still going to be a bunch of spider-man 3
stuff happening they're filming the movie for a
while now but the marvel drought is finally over
we have new Wandavision episodes falcon and winter
soldier episodes coming really soon so we're doing
a giveaway for disney plush memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know where you want to see daredevil
show up in all the different marvel phase 4
movies in disney plus series i'll name a winner
at the end of this too but recently spider-man
3 went back to filming outdoors so that's how
people found out about charlie cox apparently
people were getting pictures and set videos of
the scenes apparently according to comicbook.com
charlie cox was spotted on set filming scenes
then presumably left which is why i think everyone
is saying that he's done filming his scenes
because comicbook.com was reporting that it was
just charlie cox filming scenes they didn't say
anything about him wearing his daredevil costume
it sounds like this is all legit he'll just be
in the movie briefly for cameos as matt murdock
lawyer but not so much as daredevil but i would be
blown away if he cameoed as matt murdock and they
didn't reference something or have some dialogue
or jokes about him being daredevil during the film
tom holland's version of peter parker wouldn't
know that matt murdock is daredevil inside the
mcu but matt murdock obviously would have heard
all the news reports and seen all the news the
dailybugle.net j jonah jameson screaming about
peter parker being spider-man that would make
sense i think that when the daredevil spider-man
3 rumors about him showing up in the movie started
last year most of us just assumed that it would be
a minor cameo scene and it would just be marvel's
way of saying hey this character from the marvel
netflix shows will continue inside the proper mcu
projects back when marvel and netflix canceled
the daredevil series the marvel people announced
that daredevil would be back this was not the
end of the character so it was just a matter
of time before they announced a new daredevil
project the real question at the time was just
what it would be would he show up in a new
series would he show up in the mcu movies
so it sounds like kevin feige always had
some plans for the future of the character
the reason why they probably haven't talked about
it sooner because they have all the marvel disney
plus series spinning up those characters
are a natural fit for those kinds of series
mostly has to do with a cooling off period
in marvel's contract with netflix it stated
that if they canceled any of the marvel
netflix shows marvel had to wait a couple
years before they could turn around and use
those characters again in new mcu projects
and i believe that the time limit for daredevil
was up around october last year right around the
time they started filming spider-man 3 so everyone
was like now daredevil can show up again and stuff
daredevil and spider-man have a long history
in the comics they've both worn each other's
costumes to help each other out if you watch
the 90s animated spider-man series it's a total
classic all the episodes are on disney plus they
did a bunch of big spider-man daredevil crossover
episodes of that if you remember way back to the
amazing spider-man 2 that movie was intended to
set up amazing spider-man 3 just a direct sequel
but also a sinister six franchise so they were
going to do a sinister six movie that would
have been separate from amazing spider-man 3.
talk about daredevil easter eggs drew goddard
the person that created the daredevil netflix
series for marvel was also going to do those
sinister six movies for sony it's like six degrees
of separation only instead of kevin bacon it's
daredevil and spider-man daredevil is one of the
other most popular new york city-based superheroes
in marvel comics spider-man travels all over new
york city in the mcu the tom holland version
of spider-man it would make sense that they'd
eventually run into each other as vigilantes
but also because matt murdock is an attorney
that helps defend superheroes we all thought that
he could logically be part of the storyline where
spider-man has to clear his name after being
framed in docks by mysterio the interview that
kevin feige did this past week about bringing
daredevil back in the marvel netflix characters
is priceless too you have to watch his reaction
when the collider guys ask him specifically about
charlie cox coming back this is pretty funny do
you is there any chance that charlie cox could be
back as daredevil or do you consider what happened
with netflix almost like an alternate universe you
know i look at anything that has happened before
uh whether it's our movies whether it's marvel
entertainment tv series in particular obviously
the comics video games cartoons all of it is uh
is uh um available as inspiration uh for uh
for uh the future of marvel that's the way
the comics have worked for 80 years so
so uh uh we'll see got it i think a lot
of people really loved charlie in that role
and are hopeful that he can find a way back
that's just like a small part of it but when
he's asked about how they're treating the marvel
netflix shows from a continuity perspective are
those in an alternate universe are they part of
the mcu he says that anything is fair game pretty
much from the fox movies to the video games to the
comics any of the tv shows which also includes the
agents of shield stuff but i think when it comes
to that stuff it's just a case-by-case basis
but usually what you'd say is that if one of
the characters comes back from a show or a video
game or something like that then technically by
association it's all canon like even if daredevil
and jessica jones are the only actors who come
back from the marvel netflix shows to play their
characters in future mcu projects and they recast
the new iron fist per se technically the events
of all the marvel netflix series are still canon
but they'll just come up with some clever way
of explaining why iron fist looks different but
daredevil and jessica jones don't then kevin feige
doubles down on it with all that head nodding like
just you wait just you wait is about as close
as you can get to saying that it's confirmed
daredevil is coming back in the mcu without him
literally speaking the words because obviously
they're not ready to make that announcement
yet the other news about daredevil showing up
in new marvel phase 4 projects would be in the
she-hulk series next year that's going to be
10 episodes long and right now people think that
it's going to premiere around this time next year
they said that there would be a lot of surprise
mcu character cameos both heroes and villains
because jessica walters she-hulk primarily is a
lawyer defending superheroes in court so it sounds
like that's where a lot of those surprise cameos
will be happening and supposedly the series will
be set around the new york city area because so
much of the mcu on earth happens in and around the
new york city area it just makes it a lot easier
for matt murdock and daredevil to pop up in those
episodes and after that it's always possible they
could do a full season of a new daredevil disney
plus series but i think short term it's more
likely the daredevil cameos in other people's
movies in disney plus series as both lawyer
matt murdock and vigilante daredevil by night
i would love to see kingpin come back in a future
spider-man movie vince dinoprio has talked about
that a lot in the past he says he doesn't
expect to come back but he would love to do it
they'll be making spider-man movies till the end
of time so it's probably just a matter of time
before kingpin shows up in an mcu project but as
far as i know he's not supposed to be a character
in spider-man 3. in terms of other marvel netflix
characters coming back there was news recently
that jessica jones was in talks to come back
for a cameo during the she-hulk series as well
because she also works in the legal arena
by day lives in new york city but i don't
know if she'd come back for the same episodes as
daredevil or they'd appear together or separately
mike coulter has said that he has not had
any talks with marvel about coming back as
luke cage yet john bernthal has also said that
he'd love to do more punisher in the mcu but
i haven't heard anything about punisher coming
back anywhere anytime soon yet iron fist is the
only character i'm not expecting to come back from
the marvel netflix shows i think if we see a new
iron fist in the mcu just right now based on the
direction things are going it's more likely he'd
show up as a character through the future shane
chi sequel movies just because those movies feel
like a more natural fit for that kunlun martial
arts mythology and during all these interviews
the past week kevin feige also responded to the
spider-man 3 rumors about toby mcguire andrew
garfield all the spiderburst stuff he said that
some of those rumors are true and some of them
are false and what i think he means when he says
some of it's true is that yes they are doing legit
spider-verse stuff during the movie electro from
the amazing spider-man 2 and doctor octopus from
the toby maguire spider-man 2 movie have already
been confirmed so yes i do think they're trying to
get andrew garfield and toby maguire themselves
to come back as their versions of spider-man
that casting news is probably true but some of
those characters are probably not going to be as
big a part of the movie as you think they are like
a lot of it will probably be smaller scenes just
straight up cameos and when he says some of the
rumors are not true there have also been wilder
rumors about willem dafoe coming back as his
version of green goblin emma stone coming back as
gwen stacy even though she is super pregnant right
now if you've seen any of the recent pictures of
her there were rumors about kirsten dunst coming
back as mary jane there was a new rumor about
them trying to get leonardo dicaprio to come in
cameo as a version of spider-man because at one
time he was going to be james cameron's version
of spider-man back in the 90s when james cameron
was trying to make a spider-man movie before sam
raimi came in to do the tobey maguire movies and
i am sure there's going to be even crazier rumors
before we start seeing the spider-man 3 trailers
and before the movie comes out in december they
reschedule the morbius movie to october but it
still seems like venom 2 is coming out in june and
spider-man 3 will release in december those dates
will probably stick which means we'll probably
get that first spider-man 3 trailer sometime
between the black widow movie release in may
or the summer with venom 2. there's been a lot
of rumors that they're waiting to lock down a lot
of these cameos like toby maguire andrew garfield
before they start promoting the movie in
a big way because of course if they were
going to be in the movie you would want to put
them in all the trailers congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
andre henderson please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your contact
details and everyone click here for my marvel
Wandavision episode 1 and episode 2 videos and
click here for that brand new black panther 2
teaser thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!